this is a new hierarchy he says i don't
think it's hypocritical at all
i'm more special than you are and so i
deserve certain special privileges
and these new hierarchies we're seeing
crop up all over the place
particularly with regard to left-wing
identity politics particularly in the
realm of race
there was this guy umair hak don't know
who that is
he's the director of the havas media lab
he blogs at the harvard business review
he's the author of the new capitalist
manifesto
building a disruptively better business
and he's some blue checkmark
leftist who mouths off on twitter he had
a tweet that was a little bit radical
a little bit i said only a little bit
radical even by left-wing standards
yesterday he said quote
f off already white people you enslaved
and murdered whole continents
you have yet to make any amends and even
the good ones among
you i get this grammar's not uh not not
top notch
even the good ones among pretend that's
okay
we are still living in that world and it
makes the rest of us so so sick and
weary
and disgusted with you now of course
nothing not one single thing
that he said there is true uh he is
disgusted i don't know what has
disgusted him probably his sick ideology
but this is uh this is very wrong and a
sensible society
would ostracize this person right since
we're now in the business of deciding
who and who ought to have this sort of
public speech on twitter
and who ought not to right right now
we're in a world where the duly elected
sitting president
can't be on twitter but this guy can
that's crazy it should be the opposite
this guy should be ostracized
he should not be permitted in polite
company anywhere
but we now live in this world in which
they're
we're not permitted to make any comment
whatsoever about race
unless of course it is to attack
whiteness
which we are told on the one hand is a
social construct and on the other hand
we're told it is so
real that it is sort of the dominant
force and evil
in the world
this is of course the glaring
example as to why things like white
privilege or white supremacy are just
ridiculous because there is only one
racial group that you are
not only allowed to condemn publicly but
you're actively encouraged to condemn
publicly and that of course is white
people
doesn't sound very supreme or
supremacist
or whatever to me i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you